I want you to take me up the North
Mountain we know how much you love going
on adventures on us so we wouldn't be
surprised if you left arendelle to catch
them all with Kristoff in tow we would
love to see arendelle swarming with
adorable Pokemon some could even help
Kristoff harvest ice you would probably
go after a cute fire-type Pokemon after
all you've got a fiery spirit so you
need a Pokemon BFF who can keep up with
you what does the magical world of
Disney and the exciting world of Pokemon
have in common
adorable animal sidekicks of course
today the Disney Princesses are becoming
official pokemon trainers and they're
about to catch them all watch until the
end to find out who else's pokemon of
choice is it's the exact opposite of
honest I knew you could do it Moana
chief mulatto isn't your average Disney
princess which is why she doesn't
deserve a typical Pokemon best friend no
honest spends most of her time
wayfinding and since puah and hey hey
aren't the best pets to bring on a
sailboat it makes sense that Moana would
catch a water type Pokemon Vimanas ideal
match is a Magikarp who eventually
evolved into a guy Otto's Moana would
ride through the ocean on guy rod oohs
back Aurora it's been a long time since
Princess Aurora took a really great nap
and she is feeling exhausted
that is until Jigglypuff wattled into
her life this competitive Pokemon keeps
Aurora entertained
jiggly sings to Aurora to put her to
sleep however she never draws on her
face
but if jiggly ever got close to
Maleficent she would sing her to sleep
and Aurora would take a Sharpie to her
face in no time jasmine
sorry to break it to you Aladdin but but
jasmine doesn't want to go on any more
magical carpet rides with you and zaboo
because well she's got a new whip of her
own Jasmine would find the freedom she's
always craved on top of Salomon's is
back she would spend her days flying
over Agrabah
and exploring new lands Rapunzel the
sweet and innocent Rapunzel will always
remember the first time her toes touch
the grass and she'll always remember
Ketchum tangela
a grass type Pokemon in the woods during
a nice afternoon walk with you team I do
like duckling
just like Rapunzel Tangela has a
reputation for having long and
unpredictable hair or should we say
vines tiana after Marion Prince Levine
Tiana finally opened the restaurant of
her dreams and one day when she was
taking out the trash in the back alley
she came face-to-face with munchlax who
was digging through the trash for scrap
she caught him and he eventually evolved
into Snorlax
and now Snorlax pretty much lives in the
kitchen of her restaurant waiters and
Busboys no to give him the leftovers off
every plate Anna Anna is a wide-eyed and
innocent princess who often gets
underestimated she's a sweet person with
a fiery personality so don't get on her
bad side on his ideal Pokemon companion
is Bonita Bonita is a fire-type Pokemon
who mirrors Ana's personality they would
be best friends within seconds after a
few adventures Bonita would evolve into
rapidash else's Pokemon is the polar
opposite about his Pokemon but they
still managed to get along keep watching
to find out who else's pokemon is Belle
Belle loves to read and learn new things
which is why she would do well with
psychic-type pokémon Belle and yuxi
would be a match made in the library
Yuki can provide people with extra
intelligence so if you thought that was
smart now wait until she befriends this
knowledgeable Pokemon Ariel when Ariel
was 16 years old she chose to swap her
fins for human legs so chances are she
doesn't want a pokemon who spends all
their time in the ocean but she doesn't
want one who can't swim either
Psyduck is a water type Pokemon who
would warm up to Ariel in no time she
would help him ease his headaches and he
would stop enemies from taking advantage
of her innocent nature merida ever since
Merida's mother transformed back into a
human
she missed hanging out with bears so she
went out to capture and train her sorry
just like Merida are soaring can come
off as angry and hostile but once he
warms up to his trainer he's a total
peach Cinderella Cinderella spends most
of her life hanging out with mice and
working as a maid Jaq what's all the
fuss about
so it goes without saying that min Tino
is the perfect pal for her that only is
he adorable but he loves cleaning above
all else Pocahontas Pocahontas loves
nature more than anything she respects
it and would never catch a Pokemon who
didn't want to be captured
Pocahontas would come across Torterra
and be amazed by him this grass
ground-type pokémon would follow her
around and flits would build a nest on
his back Mulan
we're sorry Mu Shu but Millan's moved on
since you helped her defeat the Huns now
she spends most of her days flying
around China on Charizard s---backed
zulan's enemies run off in a hurry when
they see her soaring through the sky
this genderless Pokemon is perfect for
the gender-fluid princess elsa honest
pokemon is fiery and grounded whereas
elseís pokemon is icy and aloof elsa
would soar through the valleys of
arendelle on artic who knows back this
legendary bird is perfect for Disney's
most legendary princess and that's a
wrap before you go tell us who your
favorite pokemon is and why in the
comments subscribe to the things and
don't forget to give this video a big
thumbs up thanks for watching we'll see
you next time
[Music]